toujours pas d'annoncé officielle pour
cette deuxième ligne de tram
le secret est bien gardé par tour
métropole parmi les différents scénarii
encore à l'étude
une sorte de colonne vertébrale semble
tout de même se dessiner
pas de vraie nouvelle ligne mais plutôt
des embranchements ou des corridors
il ya un schéma directeur qui a été
validé par l'ensemble des maires qui
regroupe les portes la porte nord saint
cyr la porte est saint-pierre-des-corps
la porte ouest autour de la riche la
porte sud autour de chambrée
saint-avertin même les extensions aussi
bien vers le nord avec la première lille
aéroport vers le sud avec le
développement au sud un nouveau quartier
de jouer des tours
c'est tout cela aujourd'hui qui étudié
et pas simplement un certain prisme pour
l'association du développement du
transport collectif en touraine
il est indispensable que cette nouvelle
ligne passe par des lieux stratégiques
de l'agglomération la gare de saint
pierre des corps par exemple ou encore
les hôpitaux
on ne peut pas passer partout de toute
façon on va être obligé de faire des
choix
le tout c'est de se rapprocher au
maximum des zones qui ont besoin du
transport collectif
donc on estime qu'au delà de 500 mètres
d'un arrêt si vous voulez les gens ne
prendront pas le crabe
donc il faut rester dans des zones de
proximité côté budget pour le moment pas
de chiffres précis à 25 millions le
kilomètre pour métropole avance qu'elle
devrait néanmoins coûter moins de 400
millions d'euros prix de la première
ligne grâce aux infrastructures déjà
créé et qui re serviront pour la
deuxième et même la troisième et
quatrième lignes déjà dans les esprits
côté calendrier on se dirige vers un
lancement des travaux en 2019 2020 et
une mise en fonction pour 2024 une ligne
centre 5 et 7 ans pour la construire
nous sommes dans les temps puisque nous
avons décidé de créer une seconde ligne
de tramway en février 2016
il ya un peu plus d'un an
donc comme on sait qu'il ya deux ans et
demi trois ans d'études voyez on en est
qu'à un tiers
une première annonce devrait être faite
avant l'été par le président philippe
briand et la concertation avec les
habitants pourraient alors commencer dès
le second semestre 2010 est